So one way of implementing prefetching
is to just add prefetch instructions
to the instruction set and
let the compiler of the programmer
figure out when to request prefetches.
So let's say we have a program
that adds up the elements
of a large array into a sum.
This program will access
these elements one at a time.
So it has a lot of spatial locality,
not much temporal locality.
And it will have a lot of misses.
With prefetching instructions, this
program will become something like this.
We still have the original program,
but in this loop,
in addition to accessing the appropriate
element of the array in iteration,
we will be prefetching an element
that we will access in the future.
Pdist here should be at least 1, so that
we are prefetching the next element, but
you might want to prefetch the next,
next or even more advanced elements.
So here, one of the trickier questions
is what should be the pdist?
How far in advance to prefetch?
If pdist is too small, for
example, if it's only one,
we end up having something like this.
Our axis is here.
We issue our prefetch in the previous
iteration for this element.
The memory latency might be this,
which means that when we do our axis,
the data still hasn't
arrived from memory.
We will still have to wait for it.
Although, we will have to wait for
it less, than if there was no prefetch.
So, here we prefetch too late, and the
access happens before the data arrives
from memory, so we still have a miss.
Although it's a slightly
less expensive one,
in terms on how long we have to wait.
However, if PDIST is too large,
let's say that the access is here,
and we prefetch this
element way ahead of time.
It arrives from memory here,
sits in the cache, and
because other elements are being
accessed in this loop all the time,
this might be eventually kicked out.
And in this case,
we say that we've prefetched too early.
So as you can see, it is not easy to
guess how far in advance to prefetch.
Furthermore, if you're
writing a program and
changing it to do prefetching, it might
be that in one generation of hardware,
the correct pdist might be,
let's say 20.
And then the process for example
becomes faster, but the memory doesn't.
And now, the processor does more
iterations while the memory is
responding so
we need to increase the distance.
So basically kind of coding
this pdist into the program
becomes tricky because
the correct value for it, so
it's not too small or too large,
changes as hardware changes.
So prefetch instructions
are very useful, but
they're not easy to get right.